Who's them? You are them. You are official. You are the highest
law enforcement agent in the land. You are them. That's you.
No, he's just one of us. They got one for us and one for them.
Does he know that Donald Trump is in the Epste files? I mean,
does he have access to the Epste files? I don't know how he would,
but I'm just staying out of the Trump thing that's way outside.
This guy This guy's like seen somebody go like get I might be
the director of the FBI. I don't know what's going on, but it
it would help if you guys called us and told us if you know anything.
I wouldn't know anything. Was told Epstein belonged to intelligence
to leave it out alone. He told his interviewers in the trumpet
transition who evidently thought that was sufficient answer and
went ahead and hired Hakasta. Who? What? Shouldn't you be fixing
that? Shouldn't you be able to fix that cash? That's like literally
what your job is.
as my goal of reviewing the Joe Rogan conversation between Cash
M Pat M Patel and Joe Rogan. Hopefully they're talking about
Epstein. Hopefully they get included in this the Elon Musk comments
because I know that that was brought up on the stream also. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did I pull this up? Oh, I
didn't add this. Hold on. There is one other thing I wanted to
add here, which was Cash Pat Mattel also apparently got swatted,
which to me is just like totally
insane. Oh, wait. I don't see it now. I lost it. Cash Patel also
talks about getting swatted which is just bizarre to me but I'll
pull that up after this talking about whether Jeffrey Epstein
killed himself or not. A lot of dislikes. I don't know. Epstein
right the reason.
Now I will say it's going to take an incredible argument on the
part of Cash Patel. Okay. An incredible argument to convince
Joe Rogan that Jeffrey Epstein actually killed himself because
Joe Rogan hasn't believed this despite everybody telling him
so for years now. Right. So if Cash Patel can convince Joe Rogan
that Jeffrey Epstein killed
really I would just be I'd be very interested because I've never
seen the person who could argue Joe Rogan into that position.
Amazing people are Do you remind me who Cash Patel is and why
anyone knows him? Cash Patel is a prolific failed basically a
middling to below average attorney college student below average
in every aspect of his life except maybe being a scammer. started
sucking Trump's dick prolifically. Started talking sucking Trump's
dick and eventually was named FBI director. He is currently the
FBI director. He has no qualifications or anything to make him
FBI director. He is a useless, but he is FBI director because
he wrote the children's book. Yes. About Trump. Exactly. We're
going to skip We're going to skip the part where he was hired
under Biden and received an award under Biden's administration.
Okay. Hired for what role? Um, he worked in what was it? The
one of the fed departments.
Let me look him up. Cash Patel. I assume he had some qualifications
to have joined the FBI or something, but let's see. I've I've
read a little bit about his career and he's uh he's been fairly
I just walked over for this. Sure. All right. Let's let's check
it out. So, in February 2019, Patel joined the National Security
Council's International Organizations and Alliances Directorate.
In 2020, he was named aid to Richard Ganell, the acting director
of national intelligence, becoming the principal deputy. Oh,
wait, but this would be um 2019 would be Trump, right? Am I cram
am I crazy? 2019 would be Trump still. And then 2020, he was
named to as an aid to to Rick Rennell, who is a Republican operative,
acting director of national intelligence, becoming the principal
deputy director of national intelligence. Hello. That's a donation.
That's Underscore with the gifted sub. Thank you very much, Underscore.
Appreciate you, buddy. Appreciate you. Appreciate you. Uh, by
the way, I added two extra hours onto the stream tonight, just
so you guys know, because we cut off two hours early last night.
That's my bad if Marty Epstein's around. Your your time is being
added to the stream. It just wasn't added last night. Okay, Marty.
So, don't feel bad about donating. I'm sorry if we missed you
last night, but tonight we're going all the way. He's not completely
unfamiliar with the FBI. So, he has some qualifications, yes,
but he is not at the top of the list. is really the biggest deal,
right? Like he is embarrassingly low and embarrassingly low on
the list. And not only that, okay, let's look let's look at his
former qualifications. So University of Richmond graduated from
Pace University School of Law in 2005. He began working as a
public defender in Miami Day County, Florida. And later as a
federal public defender for the southern district of Florida
Patel began so I from what I understand he was a poor he was
about an average to poor public defender. Okay.
average to poor a kitten house. Thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. Thank you. Thank you.
Patel began working as a junior staff member at the Department
of Justice in 2012, becoming a prosecutor in the National Security
Division in 2013 and working in count the counterterrorism division
in 2014. 2017 he became a senior aid to Devon Nunees, the chairman
of the House Permanent Select Committee on Intelligence where
he was the primary author of the Nunes memo. So basically because
he was a partisan and he did the Nunes memo which I believe is
on Crossfire Hurricane
uh what did they photoshop uh an application for a FISA warrant,
right? I believe that's what the the Nunes memo is about. Am
I correct on that? The Nunes memo uh is a four-page memorandum
written for the US uh US Representative Devon Nunees by his staff
and released to the public by the Republican controlled House
Intelligence Committee on February 2nd, 2018. The memo alleges
that the FBI may have relied on politically motivated or questionable
sources to obtain a FISA warrant against Carter Page. Yep. Yep.
That's what it was. That's what it was. I knew I knew. I knew
I knew that. So, he wrote the the Nunes memo. He was like a big
part of that. And that's I think what kind of built his name
in Republican circles was he was the guy who was calling out
the swamp, so to speak, right? I think the whole giving Elon
full access to pretty much everything while Bannon's currently
suggesting they deport him is a bigger deal. Uh, it probably
is a bigger deal. Yeah. Anyway, we're going through his bonafides.
His bonafides are okay to be a part of or a staffer for somebody
who does national security stuff in Congress. His bonafides are
not those of somebody who would be the director of the FBI
ever. Sorry, this he does not have impressive bonafides at all.
He should not be the director of the FBI. He did not climb that
ladder. He is not a career FBI man. He should not be the leader
of that organization is my point. But perhaps perhaps I overstated
how unqualified he was. Okay, he's got some small semblance.
They have some small argument that he has a little bit of qualification,
but he is not actually qualified for the role at all. Are off
about that. It's the same same thing, right? 20 years ago or
whenever it was 200678, Epste gets his sweetheart plea deal,
right? Sure. After committing the most horrific crimes on planet
Earth, right? I wasn't in I wasn't in power there. I wasn't in
place there. Oh, I will apologize profusely. As soon as there
is a full dump of the Epstein files, this looks like it was about
30 minutes ago. So, it's still going, guys. They're still going
today. I didn't really look for this at all, but yeah, they're
still going today. All right. Based, you know, nothing to do
with it, but people were rightfully I mean, this guy was committing
the most grotes act acts you can against children. So, where's
the where's the file? And the most grotes the media spins up
about it. many in the media protected. Why? Because of his relationships,
who he knew, who his bankers were, who his colleagues were, who
was on the island and stuff like that. Some pretty powerful human
beings. And so when you peel back the the layer and then you
and then what happened? The Trump administration the last go
round decided, "No, no, we're not going to let that go. We're
going to investigate him." Right? They charge him, they indict
him, and he's awaiting trial.
And I've said it, Dan Bonino said it. We've reviewed all the
information and the American public is gonna get as much as we
can release. He killed himself. Do you think let's play out the
logical Oh, this is why people are this is why it had down votes
is because people people believe that he did not himself and
when they hear that he killed himself that's going to make them
mad. This do you think that myself Bonino and others
Yes. would participate in hiding information about Epstein's
grotest activities or sorry, not intentionally. I think you guys
are incompetent and you could be fooled by basically a toddler
in a trench coat. Three toddlers in a trench coat, do you think?
Maybe because we don't know the implications of it. Like, how
could we possibly know that? But like I I think a lot of people
the thing is
that yeah, of course people would believe that that's possible.
I'm not saying it is. I'm not saying but yeah, of course people
could believe that. Especially when you say the files are coming
out and then they don't come out. Yeah, then people are worried.
We would also participate in not prosecuting people. We had evidence
to prosecute people on the problem there's been like 15 years
of people coming in and creating fictions about this that doesn't
exist. Where's the videotape of an epipene island of X Y and
Z committing these? Why haven't you given it to us? Do you really
think I wouldn't give that to you if it existed? I'm working
my act off along with the leadership at the bureau and DOJ to
get you what we're allowed to give you. And you're going to get
the video. Well, how are you allowed to? I mean, what do you
mean by allowed? I mean, you're the one that make the rules.
So, like, what do you mean by allowed?
Gash Patel is starting to realize how easy it is to be the person
without any power, criticizing the person with some power. Okay.
Huh. Asold sits here. He doesn't have the ability to make any
decisions. He's not accountable to anybody. And he goes, "Wait,
wait, wait. You're the guy who gets to do that." Uh, what the
[__] What do you mean allowed to give us? You decide
what you're allowed to give us,
idiot. Idiot
of the cell and you're going to see for yourself and we will
never be able to convince everyone. Okay, let's let's get into
that. So, what did you think before you got in office? Did you
think that Epstein was murdered? Welcome back. No, no suspicion
at all of it. But I have a different background. Well, he has
a suspicion, but you just didn't know. Yeah, sure. Right. So,
I was a public defender back in the day. I used to spend a lot
of time in jails and a lot of time in segregated housing units,
shoes as we call them. Right. Okay. And so, um, and I've known
people that have committed in these cells,
and I know how you get in, how you get out, who works the system.
And so the way based on public information at the time that he
ended up the pictures and him hanging himself, I was like, "Yeah,
that guy killed himself." It's there's
what? Okay, but Bonino, Bonino, whoever that guy is, that guy
was definitely like, "We're going to get you the files. We know
Epstein didn't kill himself." Maybe Cash Patel didn't make public
statements and he could skate on this, but I don't believe that
he would have been nominated for the FBI with that position,
right? That's like not the popular Republican position. What
are we saying? There's no way that [__] hate you
could have run.
Why the particularly bad cat litter box break?
No, I just had to reset the machine to like turn and stuff. I
I ordered cookies and they sent me chocolate chip instead of
oatmeal raisin.
Oh yeah. Life truly. It's like not even close to oatmeal raisin.
Yeah. It's like a dude. Sometimes it's like why go on chocolate
chip instead of oatmeal raisin. That's I'm gonna cry. Please
I was really looking forward to the oatmeal raisin cookie.
Sorry. I'm also laughing at Kenny being Kenny's like good. Kenny
just said good. He's like you. You call me dumb. I hate chocolate
chip cookies.
unlucky. Unlucky. We'll find we'll find a way to persevere. Okay.
How can we make Kenny suffer? There really is no way to make
Kenny suffer. Kenny is just No, there is a way. Make him react
with you to this. I feel like that's what suffering is right
now. Get in here. Kenny, I don't know. I don't know about that.
Had people go into that cell and not have any video of it and
not have any people come out and say, "Hey, yeah, I saw that
guy. He shouldn't have been there. The guard or this guy." There's
just no access points into places like this in the detention
center he was in, which I've been in. So, correct me if I'm wrong,
but what I if we if we do that, Kenny's going to come in and
want to argue and then I'm never going to get through my I got
so much content to get through today. It's
Okay, Kenny, I was thinking about like arguing. I just assume
he would have to like come here, sit here, and wait, hold on.
No, no, no. Like Cash Patel is interesting. Wait, no, no, no,
no, no. You actually have you ever watched a Kenny stream? No,
no, no. Sorry, Kenny. Don't join. I lied. Don't join. Have you
ever watched a Kenny Kenny stream? Kenny hops on stream and plays
video games for 12 hours and literally says four words the entire
time. He talks way more on my stream than he'll talk on his own
stream, right? But like he will actually just never speak during
his stream. So if you think he's incapable of coming on here
and saying nothing, you vastly underestimate Kenny's power. Okay.
Apparently he type while he's sleeping because he just typed
that he is sleeping. He did do that which is pretty cool. He
also what did he he came and yelled at somebody in VC yesterday.
Somebody tagged him last night when we were arguing and he like
came in. He's like, "Never tag me again." And then he like hung
up immediately. Kenny, do you not remember that? Do you not remember
doing that, Kenny? He yelled at Zezy for tagging him. He was
like, "Never do that again." And then he just disconnected. And
he didn't come back and say like it's just a joke or anything.
He was just like mad. And we assume we woke him up. Yeah.
Yep. Yep. That happened. I was told what I'd read was that the
guards were not paying attention or were
Well, right. Yeah. And in short order, you'll see it. Is that
is that correct? Well, it's hard to surmize that. Casper Gold
look like he is so deep in thought. I can't take this man seriously.
He's a modern philosopher. Okay.
He's he's unraveling the mysteries of the universe as And in
short order, you'll see it. Is that is that correct? Well, it's
hard to surmise that from a video, right? like where they like,
you know, and look, do guards doze off on the night shift? Yeah.
But no one can get in to the cell and if they had gotten into
the cell, you would see it. But we were told that the cameras
were down. Well, I don't know who said that. But that was that
was in the news. Yeah, that was the official narrative that the
cameras went down, he died, and then the cameras came back up.
Um, we're giving you all the footage we have.
Dude, how does this h This is like what makes people believe
in the swamp unironically is this guy's like a total populist.
Hates every institution. He shows up and he's like, "I'm giving
you everything we could possibly have." Okay, I don't know what
you guys want me to say. My family.
It just sounds we It's crazy that he's like totally flipped on
everything he he would have said before he became the FBI director.
Mhm. Um we're giving you all everything that he did say cuz there
was he did podcast before he got um selected.
Yeah. And he talked about like all the corruption and how he's
going to root it all out and and then this is what we get. Can't
even prove Epstein didn't himself. No, no, no. That's not an
answer, bro. Like that's not This is See, this is the reason
why people are getting worried and they're starting to cap on
this is because they just said, "No, no, cuz he said, listen
to what he just said.
Well, that was that was in the news. Um, we're giving you all
the footage we have. That is not an answer to whether the cameras
went off or not. That is a separate answer to a different question
that wasn't asked.
That released like immediately. Why Why did this speculation
escalate?
I think you'd have to ask uh whoever the attorney general back
then was. Bill Bar, did you ever see Do you remember that HBO
autopsy show? Dr. Michael Baden, he's a famous forensic I don't
think I scientist. So, uh, he's a pathologist and he reviewed
somebody hitting a bong right now case and it was his determination
that it was a homicide because of the way his neck was broken.
He's got a cigar, right? Cigar. cigars. It was it was indicative
of a liature strangulation and it was because of the positioning
on the neck where the marks were that it wasn't indicative of
someone hanging by their weight which had been higher on the
chin and there's a specific break of the bro Joe Rogan knows
this case open and shut. What the Joe Rogan is so informed for
the first time ever. Joe Rogan like knows every aspect of the
ep scene. Oh, sorry. Bones and the vertebrae. It's consistent
with someone who is just
I haven't seen it. The thing is that whether Epstein killed himself
or not is like in my opinion not really the big that's not the
big thing. He's dead. What about all the other people that were
involved with him?
You're telling me that you haven't even been able to get a single
name of a single person? Not even one person. Gillis Maxwell.
Well, yeah, but she was like his accomplice, right? This is a
very different thing. Not a single person. Definitely take a
look at it cuz that's part of my job. He's going to have to look
at it. You haven't seen that. The report I haven't looked at.
Did he have like trauma to like his spine or his feet or anything
like that or his like abs based on him landing like that or that
Did you see any kind did was there any other autopsy done other
than the official one?
Not to my knowledge, but if there was, you'll get it. And that's
what we're doing. See if you can find that doc Dr. Michael Baden
thing. Did you remember that show? The HBO show. No, they're
going to watch it together. This guy Dr. Michael Oh, that's good.
And he had a long career of catching murderers, you know, exuming
bodies, finding trace amounts of poisons, different kinds of
things. And it was a crazy show, like all these wild ways. Well,
I love watching shows and I spent a lot of time on Yeah, it was
an old show. It was a show like from the early 2000s, I believe.
Um, but this guy was like, you know, this very wellrespected
forensic scientist who would analyze these bodies, and it was
his determination that he was murdered. Yeah. And my job going
back to the core of what I've been doing because that's the first
time Frank forensic scientists have lied for the government.
True. His feet hit the ground but not before he broke his neck.
Okay. All right. Trump posted this today. This is This is just
like the most suspicious thing I've ever heard. David Shown,
I was hired to lead Jeff Jeffrey Epstein's defense as his criminal
lawyer 9 days before he died. He sought my advice for a month
before that. I can say authoritatively, unequivocally, and definitively
that he had no information to hurt President Trump. I specifically
asked him, "Yeah, okay. That's really funny." Listen, I asked
him, "Can you hurt President Trump?" And he said, "No, I could
I I couldn't possibly." What? Someone put this man on camera
right now. Let me see the bruises on his face, on his hand. Yeah,
sure. What did they do to him? The Mitch McConnell like bruised
up hand like the half like the mangled hand. Yeah. Yeah. Something's
going on. He just goes, "Yep." All right. Well, anyway, so uh
like I I guys Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know. I like I love watching shows. Yeah,
guys. I just No, I don't think I think he was just acknowledging
that what Joe said, right? He's just like, "Oh, yeah. Yeah, I
see what you're saying." I mean, this guy saying that he got
murdered isn't definitive, but like there sure seems like there's
a lot of stars aligning in order for this to occur. Like, I'm
not certain. Like, Cash Patel could be telling the truth. And
it is could it could be possible that he did just straight up
kill himself and that's that's possible. But again, I think the
reason why people don't believe that is that nobody else's head
has rolled because of this. There's been no other trials. And
so when you have this like massive like this this massive thing
that happens and people are going to jail for trafficking, but
who are they trafficking to and from? How is this happening?
Where are the logs? Where is all of this stuff? How credible
is the source? I mean, the cameras are off. Yeah, exactly. Where's
the client list? Yeah, Epstein's accomplice, Pierre, literally
died the same way under the same circumstances. Well, that's
convenient. But like and like so the thing is I think a lot of
more a lot more people would would believe that Epstein killed
himself if there were convictions and at least uh you know like
people getting arrested for being involved with this, right?
So like if I if I saw them doing arrests over and over and over,
I would say, "Oh, okay. Yeah, maybe he did kill himself." But
it's both of these and all these things coming together. That's
the reason why people don't trust it. Yeah. Uh guards asleep,
cameras off, all the junk. And the weird thing I will say is
I don't know like how much testimony is there. It seems like
I guess it would be like a tight loop. I just don't know how
much testimony there is about what went on on Epstein's Island,
right? But I guess if they're all blackmailed, then yeah, there
wouldn't be. Nobody would be talking about it, right?
Yeah. I think the it's how many
people don't get caught doing something, right? Yeah. Sure. And
as Yeah, exactly. And as evil Johnny pointed out, like there's
no reason to believe that he couldn't have been encouraged into
himself, right, by people who were trying to cover things up,
right? So nobody gets caught because they basically tell him
like, "Oh, we know where your family is and we are going to kill
them unless you take care of it yourself, right?" which is like
a fairly famous thing to do. But yeah, it is the idea that nobody
else is getting caught. There is nobody else here. What's going
on? What? How? How did all these kids get abused? How did this
go on for so long? There's this whole like allegation of blackmail
rings and ain't nobody ain't no how are they blackmailing them?
Nobody got caught. It's way more likely than someone him in prison.
Sure, but I just I don't I don't know where is where's all of
the evidence. It it is something you kind of wonder about like
how did this all just disappear? Going to sell hard drive corrupted
detective. Exactly. How many stars have to align in order for
this to happen and it just so conveniently happens in the way
that protects all of these really powerful people that are billionaires.
I don't know guys that seems pretty seems like a
Isn't that just weird? I just feel like it's a little weird.
Isn't that a little strange that it went down like that guys?
I just feel like that's kind of odd personally. Like it's just
a little weird. little strange to get everybody the information
at this point. Aspen
Aspen and like other terminally online streamers are probably
like the only people who can actually call this out cuz we know
definitively like they don't leave their houses. They're not
involved in this. Everyone else is concerning. Asmin Gold is
not in any conspiracy. Okay. We we can account for this guy's
presence like 20 hours a day. Amaran's
logs. Yeah. Amaran's clean too. Okay. She sits on stream 20 hours
a day. She's safe. Epstein's autopsy points to homicide. Pathologist
hired by brother claims New York City medical examiner strongly
disputed the claim that the evidence from the autopsy this is
just one person. You can't be sure this is it's true or not.
But again, it's not even about he's already dead. It's not like
finding out that he didn't kill himself is going to bring him
back to life and then we can get a testimony out of him. Like
you suggested trying anyone do about it? Yeah. Nobody. By the
way, this is the New York Times and they never lie.
The private pathologist,
Dr. Michael Baden, said the morning TV show Fox and Friends,
Mr. Epstein, experienced a number of injuries, among them a broken
bone in his neck that are extremely unusual in hangings and could
occur much more commonly in homicidal strangulation. I think
the evidence points to homicide rather than Dr. Batten who observed
the autopsy done by city officials. Dr. Baden, a former New York
City medical examination and a Fox News contributor said, "I
have not seen
that last one makes me a little concerned where that occurred
in hanging case."
The only way that this makes sense why they're not releasing
the
I think that the Biden administration didn't release it on Trump
because it would also incriminate the Biden administration. And
I think the Trump administration isn't releasing it on the current
people because it would incriminate themselves and Republicans.
And I think the reason why you have this cold war is because
there is probably a third party that has all of the information
probably. I don't know like you could say I mean I think like
aliens or something. I think it's aliens that you know if you're
a conspiracy
oh same thing be Israel or China right? uh has all of the actual
information. And if dude, what what are you talking about? Hold
on. Weren't you just getting mad about Hassan doing some [__]
like this? What the is he saying right now?
I just missed. Why would he say that? Why would he say that?
That was a little weird. It's been a little while before we had
somebody dog whistling like that. Damn, I haven't broken out
that soundboard in forever. It's been forever. Oh my god. Yeah,
I I will say Israel is probably tied to like Galain's father,
right? Galain's father was like a famous um Israeli spy. If one
side releases it and it's not it it's not complete, then they
will release the fully complete thing. That's the only way that
it can make sense that nobody has tried to weaponize this information
and redack the parts that make their side look bad. Or Black
Rockck. I'm just saying like there's some there is a third there's
a third party whether that is black black rockck Israel World
Economic Forum Msad oh wait sorry that is Israel um I guess he
said China Putin uh a hacker group I have no idea uh findings
by Dr. Baden were strongly disputed by the city's chief medical
examiner Dr. Barbara Samson who previously ruled that Mr. Abs's
death on August 10th in the Metropolitan Correctional was stand
firmly.
Oh man, it would be so fun to ask if that's why he thinks that
Trump's allowing um Israel to run over Gaza right now, right?
Is because Israel has the blackmail. Israel, obviously Epstein
was an Israeli spy, right? Israel is the blackmail and now they
have a blackmail over the US president. So now they're just running
rough shot. Maybe that's why they started doing it under Biden,
too. On our determination of the cause and manner of death in
this case, Dr. Samson said in the interview on Wednesday, she
added, "In general, I hate how you can always tell when it's
a performative conspiracy theorist, in my opinion, when they
won't engage in that." By the way, when they're like a conspiracy
theorist and they're willing to follow every thread, but then
it goes like kind of near Israel and they have like this self
protection thing, this like self uh preservation instinct where
they're like, "No, no, no, I'm not going over there. Nope, I'm
not going over there." Right. I would be cool to hear Asminold
get asked about this. Okay. Israel is nothing on Biden. Biden
was clean. Biden didn't kiss the wall. I know that. But I feel
like um there's like a lot of conspiracy theories around it.
You don't have to be anti-Semitic, but I'm just saying that like
when somebody like when when you can tell from how they treat
everything that they would normally be willing to do it, they'd
normally be willing to go down that rabbit hole and then they
won't when it's Israel. I feel like that's the easiest way to
tell somebody's like a total grifter. Total grifter. No actual
beliefs. That's just the microchips in the water and it makes
us unable to target Israel. No, it's not. It's uh self-preservation.
Okay. Fractures of the hyoid
boneage can be seen in and homicides. The hyoid bone is near
the Adam's apple. Dr. Samson also dismissed Dr. Bad's contention
that the circumstances around Mr. Epstein's death. Is kiss the
wall a phrase or literally kissed the wall? Literally kissed
the wall.
Literally kissed the wall. It's the whailing wall. It's the western
wall of the the is it temple of David? It's the second temple,
right?
Yeah. There's like a place in Israel that they It's like a literal
wall that people kiss. It's the wall of like the the second I'm
positive it's the second temple. And yeah, they that you kiss
the wall. You you like put your prayers in the wall. Yeah. That
suggest and there like basically every prolific US politician
has gone to Israel, made a trip to Israel and kissed this wall
except Biden. Biden didn't do it. Can't find a picture of Biden
near the wall. Okay. Said other people may have been involved.
She said her office had done a complete investigation taken into
consideration information gathered by law enforcement in the
making in making the determination. I can't wait for Joe Rogan
to finish reading all this and then Cash Battel to just be like,
damn, that's crazy.
So, this is a perfect example of going back to my public defender
and prosecutor days. Yeah. This is what we call a war of experts.
You can always find someone, right, to come in and say the opposite,
right?
To be fair, what he's saying now is completely
true. He is completely right about that. And I remember, listen,
I watched the entire Johnny Depp trial. I will never look at
experts the same after I watched that trial. And I used to do
it all the time. I mean, I represented some of the worst humans
that you can possibly imagine on Earth. Literally, the guys that
uh were trafficking children from Mexico into America. That's
bad. That's bad. That's really bad. A professional. protecting
them. Say, I'm just kidding. I don't Yeah, I don't know. Why
is this supposed to help? And this is what's going to go on forever.
Yeah, I don't know. And my job is not the forever. My job is
to get you absolutely everything that we can give you. And that's
what we're going to do. When did you become aware of this video
that showed that no one had gone in and out of the cell recently?
So, why was it recent though? I mean, if this death was How long
ago was this death? Two years.
Couple 2019. 2019. So, let me get this
straight. One of the most noteworthy people that is connected
to presidents and other heads of state
internationally
themselves and they thought the cameras were off, but recently
they found out now that the cameras were in fact on and they
had a recording of it. Oh, connected Asthma Gold. right after
Google finishes their like new AI video technology. And now suddenly
with this AI technology, we suddenly realized we had the Epstein
recordings the entire time. That's what you're telling me? Is
that what you're saying to me? Huh? Okay. Huh? Oh, really? Oh,
time flies. So, six years. Wow.
Well, again, that's part of what I'm going to try to answer for
you. Jeffrey Epstein JLCC TV erased by technical errors. Whoopsies.
Ah jeez guys. Ah bro. Oops. Uh was destroyed by act. Oh it was
destroyed by a a god damn it man.
Who isn't that? Did Phil do that? A he he erased the tape again.
Oh it happens.
But you see how anybody on the out I mean this. Okay guys we're
going to end on Twitch and send people over to kick. Okay. So
just about at four hours. I'm just realizing I can do it right
now in the in this little lull we've got here. So, here's the
kick link over in the Twitch chat, guys. Head over to kick
kick.com/jdlk. I'll pin that link over on Twitch for a little
bit and we're we're heading over there. So, I will see you guys
shortly. Okay, see you in a bit. Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye. It's like a perfect storm for some. Can you pull that
article up so we can read what it says, Jamie? Yeah. US prosecutor
said the jail mistakenly saved footage from the wrong cell. Sorry.
Epste, a convicted offender, first tried to kill himself in July
last year and hanged himself in jail. Hang on, hang on, hang
on, hang on. Yep. Reread that line that he first tried to kill
himself in July of last year. How much of the American public
do you think knows that? I didn't know that until right now.
There you go. Maybe I heard what that Yeah, that was the Wait,
what? What are these guys? They're the weakest conspiracy theorists
I've ever seen.
What? Yeah, of course you know that. that like he got roughed
up by his roommate and then it was like, "Oh, did he like try
to kill himself or what happened here?" And then he said he didn't
try to kill himself. Heard it and forgot. Did you ever hear it,
Jamie? Well, he was on That's why he was on watch, I think. Oh,
okay. So, a guy hang himself in jail in August while serving
trial. I thought there was contention over whether it was his
roommate that roughed him up, right? That's why he got moved
to the cell he was in. Yeah, he was on watch when he died. That's
what makes it crazy. Federal trafficking charge. She pleaded
not guilty to abusing dozens of girls, some as young as 14. Soon
after Epstein's death in August, two of the CCC CCTV cameras
outside his cell malfunction. You know what? I want to do a poll.
Let's create the poll. And it's broken. We'll we'll we'll do
it later. We don't care what Assat thinks and we're being wait.
That's awesome that his editor left that in. I want to do a poll.
So, here's the poll. Okay, it broke. Never mind. You know what?
I want to do a poll. Let's create the poll. And it's broken.
Well, we Well, you know what? Sorry, I had to pause and see what
the options were. He actually just killed himself. They let him
kill himself. They killed him. He's still alive. Option five
or option probably somewhere in the middle should be they made
him kill himself. They made him kill himself. The poll and it's
broken. We'll we'll we'll do it later on. Maybe at the end of
the video.
And we're being examined by the FBI.
semi-conscious with injuries. We know who they is. On 25th of
July, what do you mean who is they? We know who they is. He already
said it. He thinks he fools us when he switches up between Israel
and MSAD. He like says them both in different instances, right?
And he thinks he's fooling anybody, but he's really fooling nobody.
We see you, Asmin Gold. We see what you're trying to do over
here. We can see he's placed on. Well, couldn't you cross reference?
Couldn't you cross reference that on his neck? because there
was obviously a medical report of that and then the injuries
after he killed himself to see if they lined up. Couldn't you
do that?
Every single camera in the place was working. I'm saying we've
got footage. You're getting it. You're getting it. When When
are we getting it? Are we getting it like tomorrow? Are we getting
it at some point? Are we going to get it in like a week? Like
when is this going to happen? It then you can make up your own
mind and
the theories can continue. But my job. So you you became aware
of this footage recently. The ones that we're looking at. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And so but this is like an art. Mhm.
Hold on. That's the face of a liar was what Ry was saying. I've
never seen a picture of Cashel where he doesn't look terrified.
Okay. Now I have. There were a couple. But he looks terrified
in a lot of these. Okay. Like
actually it looks like resting terrified face. Yeah. Like it's
I don't know. Yeah. Of course he's alive. Of course he's like
in over his head. But also, what if this is the opposite of the
vibe you're like picking up? The things that he said before he
became FBI director. He he wanted to just like be what is it?
Transparent. He wanted to show stuff to the public, not have
the government be so secretive. And now he goes on this podcast
and he's like, "Yeah, we got this footage and you're going to
get it, too." Sure, it's possible. I like my I I like resting
terrified face better though. I'm sorry.
Okay. Article from quite a while ago that was saying that the
footage was mistakenly I lied on my resume for this job phase.
That's a little bit too goes back to the same
ask the people that were in power then. I mean I get it that
you want to hold me to account for their actions and No, I'm
not saying not you. I'm not saying that. Not you that just the
the public in general and that's okay. What's confusing to everybody
today? First of all, it's very confusing because AI can kind
of make anything. you know, which has got to be a bizarre position
for you to be in when you're looking at videos. I mean, I've
watched Viking videos, look real as, you know, they just make
Viking towns. I mean, it's really quite incredible what they're
doing now and it it accelerates every month. I mean, I talked
to Elon about it. He said, "We're blown away." Literally every
week, every week there's some new breakthrough. We're like, "Wow,
we didn't expect that." Well, I can tell you after having looked
at it, this ain't going to be AI. You don't think so? you're
going to it's it's just not great. You know, it's like if it
were AI, like someone wanted to come in and make it, they'd make
it better. But why would you make it better when people could,
you know, you could have ambiguous footage that
Joe Rogan is at this is this is actually crazy that he's This
is like a genius question, right? Of course, they would make
it look bad to make it more believable. Of course, they wouldn't
make it that clean. Then it would be obvious. Joe sees that it
is. It's not going to thing for Cash to point out like, "Oh,
no. It's not AI cuz it's like
I feel like Asmin Gold's about to glaze for no reason. It's going
to be very annoying. Asking these questions. This is This is
more like Yeah, this is peak. Yeah, I know he's actually asking
this. Yeah, bro. Can you imagine like how h this is peak? This
is guys, can you believe Joe is this? Alex Jones is going to
be whenever he sees this video. Like, yeah, he he's going to
be so happy is, you know, totally generated by Jones. I'm sorry.
When does Asmin Gold care about Alex Jones? Asmin Gold's a conspiracy
theorist at heart. Of course, he cares about Alex Jones. Oh,
really?
That was like a dead-on Warren Smith. It kind of was a dead-on
Warren Smith.
what? Guys, that is exactly right. That was like peak, actually.
Sorry, I said he was a conspiracy theorist. What? Yeah, he's
just a conspiracy theorist. Sorry, I was I saw the words popped
in my brain. Does it? What has Warren Smith been doing?
Uh making videos all the time. Yeah, I'm I've seen some of his
videos. I had one in a in a thing a couple weeks ago, but I took
it out. We'll have to get back to him at some point. We will.
We'll get back to him at some point. He's our favorite pseudointellectual.
Okay. Well, yeah, he's our favorite. I think he's my favorite.
I shouldn't say ours. I don't know. I don't know if he's yours,
Cherry. He is one of the best.
Okay. Wait, who's your favorite? I don't know who my favorite
is, but it's definitely not going to be the dude who films outside
with like a terrible mic and all I can do is hear birds chirping.
Yeah, fair enough. Blurry images. AI can generate night vision.
AI can generate essentially anything that's already existed like
really
84 VHS tapes. They can do that. I've seen that. But I'm telling
you, I'm giving you the tape from the tape.
You know, there's just like I'm giving you the documents from
the vault. Just like I'm giving you information to Congress on
CO origins or what have you. What we find is what you're getting.
Okay. So, now it's saying 2019 missing jail video from the Oh
jeez. Oh jeez. Now we've got another article. Oh, here's another
one. But this is from before the previous article. So, I'm very
confused on this timeline. Yeah. Um, so here's the problem. As
I said, if people were getting arrested and getting locked up
for the Jeffrey Epstein stuff, I would believe that he killed
himself 100%. Is he going to comment on the timeline? Again,
I I don't think that it's impossible to come to the conclusion
that he did in fact himself. But the problem is that this is
happening at the same time that there are no consequences for
anyone at all. And it's this complete opaque like uh incomprehensible
[__] That's the reason why it's bad. Did your voice
your cry? I don't think so. Um I just I feel like the problem
with the Epstein stuff is we don't know like we we know like
three allegations and then we all blow it up into something that
happened you know systematically for years and years and years
and years and there was just tons of kids abused. Realistically
we don't know that for a fact. We kind of assume it because obviously
there are trips to the island and he had a plan a pattern of
doing it with certain people. So like you think that and I think
there's some allegations from like one or two of the girls, right,
that it was more prolific, but like there is no and there might
never be evidence. So it's like we're all expecting people have
to go down for this. But realistically, if we have no evidence
that the crimes even happened beyond like two pieces of testimony
or something, I don't know how you could What are they arresting
people on? I would arrest everybody who's been photographed with
Diddy. I just start there. I mean, so there's an argument for
that. Like if you have a name in the flight logs to the island.
Well, I I unfortunately like if you have your name in the flight
logs to the island, like realistically that's pretty concerning
all on its own, right? Yeah. Like if your name is there and then
we also have a photograph of you with Diddy, I just I feel like
that just proves everything. Just gone. Yeah. Yeah.
I think that that's enough evidence for Elon's claim against
uh Trump. Did you see? Hold on. Were you here when I pulled up
this tweet? I don't know if you were here. Yeah. What's this?
I will apologize profusely as soon as there is a full dump of
the Epstein files. Elon says so. He's he's maintaining it today.
Okay. I don't know. Is this the first person to ever call the
president of the United States a repeatedly
like like sorry first like rich rich and successful person.
Yeah, it seems to be right. I can't think of I can't think of
somebody who is like a billionaire who's calling like the president
of the United States a openly in like newspapers is basically
what this is and what is he going to do because that does not
even take a joke right that's he like stopped doing those dinners
cuz he didn't like the whole make fun of the president portion
there's she just had a mask of him and she basically like lost
her career for
ever does she do anything now what's her name Kathy
Kathy Griffin. Kathy Griffith. One of the two. And yeah, I don't
know what she does. I have no idea. Elon calls everyone a PDF.
Yeah, but it's the president of the United States. And it's like
the most vengeful, vindictive president of the United States.
Yes. And fragile president of the United States ever. I understand
you guys are saying Elon calls everyone a
It's the president of United States. Rocket Man. Okay. He's not
going to deal with this for much longer.
I I don't know what's going on,
Yeah, it's that's a stupid argument. No, I don't think that it
is because so
basically getting Chinese EVs now, but I think they they might
have cut the Chinese EVs out of Canada. Dude, the Chinese Aren't
the Chinese EVs like basically hitting like a lot of the milestones
that Teslas are, but they're like literally $15,000. They're
like 105. I thought they were like insanely insanely cheap. Aren't
they like
ludicrously cheap? Are they really better? Technology is better.
Yeah. Damn. Because Tesla's been like detourred in the wrong
direction for a decade or something. Bro, I got a cheaper. The
BYV Eagle is less than 9K. Good ones are less than 10K. What?
Chinese EVs are out selling Teslas in EU now.
Someone can correct me if I'm wrong, but the Chinese EVs, they
actually can do self-driving, right? I don't know. Um, I do think
it's terrifying the concept of like putting all these Chinese
EVs in the US and then potentially having them record like location
data on tons and tons of civilians. That seems like that could
be a national security risk. No. Yeah. So is Tik Tok, right?
All of it's a security risk. Yeah. And China's willing to just
put it over here for like nothing. They're willing to sell everything
at like a loss for no reason. It's it's a conspiracy every time.
It's so crazy.
I don't need FSD on an EV that cost me eight grand. It's like,
dude, I would buy one of those EVs just to have one at that price
point, right? Like, I would think about just buying one. I understand
that's like expensive, but realistically, it's like half of an
Apple Vision Pro, isn't it? What's an Apple Vision Pro? What
is that like 4K?
Apple Vision Pro. Yeah, this is five grand or some [__]
Like, yeah, if I can get a Chinese EV for what this costs Oh,
this might be Canadian prices. I think I'm on my Yeah, I'm on
Canada. Okay, this is Canadian prices. But still, like three
times, like a 3x on this to get just a a little electric car
you can go your groceries in. That'd be awesome if he didn't
kill himself. And so, let me let me think of a way to say this
that makes sense. So basically, if the argument is that he actually
just killed himself and it's just a freak accident that all the
stars happened to align that these things, you know, like just
happened, what about all of the other evidence involved with
this entirely? It's that nothing with this is moving forward.
Himself is just simply a point of reference. It's one point on
the graph of the straight line that reads like there is corruption.
You see what I'm saying? Statute of limitations. Then put the
information out regardless.
It then if you can't try them and put them in jail, put the information
out anyway and torch their reputation. Joe is asking a real question.
That might be fair, right? Just literally print the whole black
book. Like, yeah, okay. Well, we can't charge them with a crime.
We literally don't have the evidence, but we're just going to
print the whole black book cuz these people, right? That might
be a thing. Questions other journalists should strive. Yeah,
exactly. Devstein killed himself. This is the poll from chat.
Only 6% of people think that he killed
himself. That is insane. Think about that level of that is I
would have I could have guessed that. I could have been like
within two percentage points. I would have said five 5% for sure.
That would have been my guess. Trust in the government. First
Jeffrey Epste attempt has been found.
So maybe let's put it into perspective.
Jails are not the most efficient, bestrun
places. It's not like
Fort Knox. Yeah. No, it's not. It's Yeah. You know, we're working
with what we got. What about uh What about all that gold at Fort
Knox? So, we never got
Whatever happened to visit? Yeah. We're They Oh, they forgot.
Well, they ain't remember. Oh, and listen, this guy's not the
only Were they going to go and verify the go? Why is that even
a conspiracy that's worth entertaining or caring about that like
the US might not have the same amount of gold reserves they state?
What is the what is the purpose of Well, I understand I understand
um Keynesian economics and the gold standard and all of the conspiracy
around modern monetary theory. I understand that. But why would
even auditing Fort Knox for gold be relevant? I don't even get
why that would be like a thing that would like Yeah, you you
would think they they could easily get rid of the gold. And it's
like it's not that it's backed by gold. The dollar isn't backed
by gold, right? Like if they had any other stores of value in
Fort Knox, it would totally offset. It doesn't need to be gold.
It It doesn't Yeah, it means nothing. So, I just don't understand
why that would be I don't understand why people even care.
The vault is empty. But how much is even in like hold on Fort
Knox gold reserves? What's the percentage of GDP that it has?
143 million troy ounces of gold. Approximately 56% of the United
States gold reserves. But how much is No, hold on. I'm trying
Why Why won't this
worth? 383 billion. So that's like
uh US
GDP. So it's literally like it's a little over 10% of the US's
GDP is in Fort Knox and gold reserves. It's like how the is that
even significant? I understand a lot of money, but is that even
significant when the US yearly GDP is 27.72 trillion? Like it
feels like it's nothing. So like why do we care? Why would you
care about the gold reserves in Fort Knox? Who who the even cares?
10% is a lot. It's a lot of money. I'm saying that like in terms
of if it was if it was half, would it matter? Would it make a
huge difference? I don't think so. That's 1%, not 10%. Oh, sorry.
Yes, 1%. Sorry, I did shift to zero. My bad. My bad. My bad.
My bad. My bad. My bad.
Anyway, where we go? Where we go? Back to this only guy to himself
in prison. It happens. I don't know how often. All the time.
Even if he killed himself in prison. So, if he if he was murdered
in prison, I as brought up that point like it was valid. And
then I don't I don't understand what anybody's talking about.
Crazy, right? You could see why very powerful people wouldn't
want if he was murdered in segregated housing in isolation after
being on watch in a place in a detention center that I physically
been in myself. It be fiction. It's just in in my experience
that is not doable. It's not doable even for the most powerful
and wealthiest people in the world. Yeah.
Um one to Yeah. I'm sure the gold the gold standard has a whole
bunch of negatives and um like it doesn't allow for growth when
your economy is actually growing either. Like it it stifles growth
really really really significantly when you can only issue money
based on like this standard of how much gold you have, right?
Like it it it does prevent you from expanding your economy or
allowing your economy to expand to meet like certain um like
demand, monetary demand.
Wouldn't you think though that I bet you'd probably figure some
[__] out like whenever I hear like you couldn't do
it like I don't know about that. That's also true, King Gro.
Yes. I mean, like I could be speaking from like I mean he knows
it better than I do. So I I could just not know what I'm talking
about. But like it sure seems like it sure seems like you'd be
able to do it. Like if if someone was in a position where a guy
could release information that could potentially damage the most
wealthy people on earth, you would have a concerted effort. That's
unprecedented. Sure. You would have the resources that we could
even possibly But let's be real, Joe. A guy who had that capability.
Hold on. There's a underscored with the five gifted. Let's Oh,
thank you very much, Underscore. Appreciate it, buddy. Appreciate
you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. By the way, we have two
hours added to the stream tonight. So, we're actually at the
4 hour mark. We're entering the the 4 hour mark. Four four plus
that's normally costing money, but last night we had two hours
left. So, we added those. Also, we are four subs away, I believe,
from another hour on the stream. We could go all night. We could
go all night. Jerry retards are conspiracy theorists or conspiracy
addicts. Yeah, they are. But I like But I I don't understand
why people can't engage with conspiracy in a healthy way. How
about all the stream you cut early? I just said I added time,
but um I love I've listened to some of the JRE episodes with
some of the UFO people and I love that, but I don't engage with
it with like this is absolutely true and the government's hiding
stuff from me. I'm just like this is fun like alt history and
like I just enjoy it. It's like fun to it's like the same reason
I'd read a fantasy book, right? But that's how I look at it.
I don't understand why most people can't engage with it that
way.
This is crazy
comprehend all pointing towards
elimin but I mean so many people have been implicated right already
and some of that information what they did to Prince Andrew and
everybody else is already out there and so that's the conspiracy
stuff that me and Bonino and the folks have to say look we will
give you everything we can and then we will have done our job
also. Wait, sorry, sorry, sorry. I'm I'm reading messages right
now. We will give you everything we can and then we will have
done our job also.
Your job? No. What?
What? Yeah. You got elected on like you were going to get people
the truth, right? Not even just the truth. You were going to
show them like who was hiding this information from them, like
what what who the swamp was. You were going to give them everything.
And as goes like, "Yeah, you promise results. In fact, you guys
all talk about how all the bureaucracy and red tape is going
to prevent you from getting results. That's why you need people
from outside the system. You guys have come from outside the
system. You have no qualifications. The only thing that your
qualification was was you're a you're you're literally like a
storming the gates of the government. You're our elected who
doesn't know why they shouldn't be talking about this. You're
supposed to go in and talk about it." And now you're coming out
and you're like, actually what they said is just exactly what
what what I'm going to tell you. They were just totally right.
Like you you are actually supposed to just be a mental patient
who goes in there and leaks all this for people. But that's not
what you're doing. Now you're like, "Oh guys, it would be really
irresponsible to like talk about, you know, the Kennedy assassination."
That's another one, by the way, that I think we just haven't
gotten any other answers on. So let me get this straight. The
president is okay with this getting
You're okay with this being released? Why? What do you mean you
can? Why would you not? Like, I understand that you wouldn't
want to release things that are like direct video evidence that
involve literal videos of underage girls. Like, I I get that.
Totally. Okay. I understand that. Yep. Yep. Yep. But what else
besides that? Yeah. Who's stopping you? If I had a shred me,
Cash Patel had a shred of evidence. Who is stopping him, guys?
Who is doing it? Who's the Russian the Jan 6 guy? The co origins
guy had a shred of evidence that this guy was murdered. I would
be the first guy to bring this case hard and fast. And I would
do even doing press conferences every week on it. The first guy.
That's what I'm asking people to play out to their logical conclusion.
I'm not Comey. I'm not Mabe. I'm not the guy that was in the
seat before.
Yeah. But what's the difference? The difference is those people
were all really competent. Those people all had decades of service
built up. Those people had spotless, impeccable records. The
only thing you have over those people is minus 30 IQ points,
which was supposed to be what we needed. That was supposed to
be what we needed to get us the truth. I have a wildly different
background. I've been putting out the truth my entire career.
Why would I risk all of it on this guy? I believe he cast the
letter. I I believe you. I mean, it would make sense because
this is bigger than anything that you that this is the big this
is the biggest one.
If you're going to risk it all for anything, it's going to be
for this one. Like, obviously, don't forget about Bangino. Bongino.
Bongino. Yeah, that guy's that guy's also, but I think he's not
anywhere near as high up as Cash Patel is, right? What is What
is Dan Bagino's
title? What is this guy? Deputy director of the Oh, he's deputy
director. So yeah, that guy is something.
Yeah, he's deputy director. He's right under Cash Patel.
God, what was he before this? I feel like I recognize that guy
from TMZ or something. I think this guy Yeah, I think this guy
was like not much. Secret Service. Oh, he was in the Secret Service.
Okay, you know what? Secret Service. That's a noble profession,
right? Also,
Bonino was the lead investigator in a car something scheme. special
agent 1999. Is it a noble profession? Didn't Trump make fun of
his Secret Service people because they didn't even do a good
job at just staying in front of him? That's like their whole
job. I No, I actually sorry in this one case I do think that
Trump was actually good. I think I think this is like almost
every other time they just let women stand in front of him. Well,
sorry, but I'm saying that like he actually people were coming
out and being like, "Women can't be in the in the Secret Service.
This is crazy." And he was like, "No, no, no. They were very
brave. They stood in front of me that they they did their job."
I think this is like the one time where he was like, "Oh, I'm
actually he's actually going to be a good person." Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Billy Joe Buché, I'm pretty sure that was the
any other time you'd be like you'd be correct in that he's being
a complete piece of [__] But no, this one I think
this one time he was actually nice to them.
Anyway, oh my god. I just think that, you know, the problem is
we've been fuming on this conspiracy for so long and it we love
conspiracies, don't we? As a as a country, there's so much I
mean, you know, they make JFK tapes. Come on. Like release the
documents. We all love them. We love them. We love UFO ones.
We love everything. We love the craziest conspiracies. They're
exciting. We don't want to hear that he tried to kill himself
in July and then succeeded in August. It would be boring. Yes,
that's at least Joe's honest, right? Stop releasing boring. Tell
me that my dreams are real, Cash. Or shut the up. Don't tell
me the truth. I don't want to hear the truth. He's like a wrestling
fan. And uh look, I could imagine why the guy wanted to kill
himself. He was going to jail for the rest of his life. And in
jail, defenders for children are not treated well. And also,
by the way, most Americans haven't, nor should they. Have you
ever spent one minute in segregated housing? No.
It's the worst. The absolute torture. Like
you and your background, you could probably handle it, right?
Like, you know, just in all reality, most Americans, you put
them in there for 5 seconds, they're going to slam their head
against the wall. Literally, they're going to lose their mind.
Yeah. Immediately. Yeah. It's that bad. It's obvious, dude. This
is I can only imagine.
This is like, do you remember Dave Chappelle did a skit about
Trump when uh after Trump became president and how he like the
first time he did a press conference after becoming president,
he was just he looked like he was ready to kill himself? Like
he was just like losing it internally. And now Cash would tell
us like a regular person, they wouldn't be able to handle the
things I know. What are people at the top of government learning
that every time they get there, they're like, "You wouldn't even
you wouldn't be able to handle what I've seen. Regular person,
they wouldn't be here to talk to you." that literally they would
have to fire our entire like upper government if they were to
go after Epstein. I feel like that's what it is. Maybe. Who knows?
And I could only imagine this guy knowing that it's over. And
what do you want to do? Do you want to Yeah. Who knows who the
he's working for? Let's just put that aside. Now, if you're working
for Let's just Sorry. Just real quick. We don't have to name
names. We We don't have to speculate. If he's working for some
Yeah. agency, some group, some
Can you even hear Can you
Sorry. Can you hear anything but like if he was working for some
national interest, some you know, some national interest, some
well-known intelligence agency, not from the US, but from another
country. If he was working for any of these things, that's all
I hear. Foreign group and they decide to target his family because
he look, he's going to jail for the rest of his life anyway.
they decide to target his family if he testifies against them.
I could see where I if I thought that it was like I'm gonna be
in jail for the rest of my life or I tell and my family winds
up being killed or or destroyed. Who knows? Maybe you'd say,
"Look, the honorable thing is Yeah. I was going to say earlier
though if Epste was really like it's much more likely that Epste
was just an asset and he was not anywhere near that he was like
an asset that was mostly managed either by like probably by national
interest whether it's the Americans or the Israelis. Okay. And
he would have been a managed like asset. He would never have
been the person in charge. If he was the person in charge he
would have had like dead man switches set up. He would have had
some way to make sure that if he got killed, right? or he was
the man in charge and he really just did just hang himself because
there's no way he would have just let like none of that. He would
have had some sort of fail safe, right? Almost certainly ended
in prison. True. Honorable cowardly thing, cowardly whatever
it is like you just Yeah. No, he's right about that. Yeah. And
I think that's obvious.
Gil saying Maxwell needs to be publicly interrogated. Why is
nothing happening with her? Yeah. Uh she's still alive, right?
Uh yeah, I know that'd be very vivic. Yeah, that's always a point
is that yeah, her dad is a a msad asset. Um, I'm just saying
he was either he was managed like literally that is what uh who
was the guy in Florida? Was it Rosenstein? It was it was literally
the AG of Florida who was going after him basically literally
said I got a call from the FBI or the CIA some like national
intelligence agency and they said he's intelligence back off.
Like you don't charge him. That's that's like on the record.
That's not even disputed by anybody. Is it is it And auntie McCabe?
Who the was it? I actually can't remember now, but it was it
was some AG of Florida literally said Aosta. Yes, it was Acasta.
Literally came out and said like, "Yeah, no, he's uh I got a
call. He was like a managed asset. I was told to to stand out."
Yeah, she's still alive. Yeah. So, what about that? That's crazy.
At some point, that guy was going back in Gen Pop. And the one
thing I'll tell you about or hold on, let me look at the let
me look at the Daily Beast article. Jeffrey Epstein's sick story
played up for years in plain sight. How did the New Yorker finance
stay nearly untouchable for decades? Vicky Ward, who has reported
extensively on Epstein and on efforts to rehabilitate him, finds
out what's changed. Oh, is this really the Daily Beast? Okay,
I'm just going to pull up the wiki. Whatever. I'll just pull
this over. This is the source in the wiki here. But uh crucially
when he was vetted for his cabinet post in the Trump administration,
Aosta said stated sorry I was told Epste belonged to intelligence
and to leave it alone. That's like what he was told. No archive.
Uh there would be an archive of it. I it's just going to be the
same thing cuz I believe it's just a a quote or something. Now
that I'm thinking about it, I feel like I looked this up and
like was this all that was here? Hold on. I'll look I'll look
for an archive really quickly. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Is the Epstein
case going to cause a problem for confirmation hearings? A Costa
had been asked. Aosta had explained breezily apparently that
back in the day he'd had just one meeting on the Epstein case.
He'd cut the non-prosecution deal with Epstein's attorneys because
he had been told to back off and Epste was above his pay grade.
I was told Epste belonged to intelligence to leave it alone.
He told his interviewers in the Trumpet transition who evidently
thought that was sufficient answer and went ahead and hired Hakasta.
Wait, but has he never spoken more on it ever? Like who told
you this? Wait, why has he never said anything? How do you how
can you just that Aosta did resign over the sweetheart deal for
what it's worth? Yeah, but like what did he never say anything?
Carter has previously denied this. Oh, no, no, no. Yeah, I just
with with Aosta, I just have no idea if he's How do you get away
with never saying
else? That's wild. Okay, whatever. Whatever. Prison systems is
the the people they eat are child predators. Yes. And he was
going to get eaten. Well known. Yeah. And they probably wouldn't
have protected him. Yeah. So the narrative has always been that
there's Oh, the quote's been disputed and the only attribution
for the quote is the Daily Beast article. I see. Never mind.
So his response to it is I didn't say it. That's what his like
actual response would be. Got it. Now, what is the chain of custody?
Do is there evidence that there is video? Is there evidence that
it was moved around, stored, protected from people looking at
it? Like, you're going to get all that information. Like, that's
literally what we're putting
man. Like, I I just I don't know, guys. How long is it going
to take to get this stuff together? It's taken a while, isn't
it? Like, I mean, to me, like I feel like this has been going,
this is just the easiest position in the world, by the way, to
just be the person with no control. I think I said this earlier,
no control. You just sit back and criticize everybody else's
work. You never ever put in any effort yourself. You're just
like, "Man, this Cash Mattel, he talked big game. Seems like
a lazy guy not getting anything done. How the did Trump hire
this guy? Why didn't Trump hire me? I bet you I could have gotten
it done. Guys, how hard is it to just go in and release information?
How hard is that? Isn't that what you do?" Uh, yeah. Yeah. I'm
tell That's what How do you think I know how easy it is, Johnny
Combo? Excuse me. I literally do it for a living. That's a hard
job. I do do that sometimes, but I try to at least temper it
with like I try to temper it with like, okay, here are like ways
that it could be more difficult. I try to temper it more than
just like the full-blown I'm just going to be like super critical
of everybody who's doing stuff, right? Cuz I kind of think this
is I've seen this play out in companies more than I've play seen
it play out in countries where I've had personal experience and
it just is bad when people when people just want to criticize,
they never provide any solutions. It's it's rough. Things turn
bad very quickly. Going on for a bit. So like what's really going
on with all this? Why is it happening? Give me a second. I got
to close some of these. There's like 50 of these things. Okay.
Yeah. This is weird. Six years.
And we're going to give you every single thing we have in Ken.
And that's the whole point. We can't fill that. I wish Joe would
ask about like what do you mean by can? Like give the second
one. Peanut. Yeah, the second one I did blow up in a uh I mean,
but I wasn't Hold on. As I literally said what the correction
should be. No, no, actually, you're totally wrong. You're actually
entirely wrong. I said exactly what the correction should be.
So, you're just totally lying right now. Sorry. I actually I
went through and said exactly where he was missing things that
were critical and helped his narrative. It's not the same at
all. Right. I'm I'm being critical of Asthold just saying it
would be easier. It would be easy. Well, hey, you're just not
doing it. Hey, you're not doing the thing I want. Right. Asmin
Gold's not saying here's what you should do cuz he doesn't know
what you should do. It's actually entirely different. My bad.
Like, I mean, can you Sorry, I tried to give that to you cuz
I tried to remain humble, but sometimes sometimes the chatter
is just totally wrong. Please give an example of something you
wouldn't be able to release and like say why you wouldn't be
able to like cuz that what does that mean, you know, and can
and this is also like it's another qualifying term. It's another
qualifying word that like I mean this is just me like I now I'm
getting cons like the more I I hear about this the more I like
again this is dude I wish my mom was still alive so she could
watch this happen if I got her on this stream and had her talking
about this honestly what I bet that stream would probably have
100,000 viewers.
I'm not I think isn't his mom's a major Trump supporter and conspiracy
theorist. Right. She was I thought that's who she was alive so
I can farm her.
Are you saying Yeah. Okay. You know, he doesn't really miss her
usually, but then he thinks about the numbers it would pull.
Not even kidding. Crazy. I'm pretty sure that's obvious. It was
insane. Like the level like cuz she was like uh she was
70. She was It's like she was crazy. But whenever it came to
conspiracy, it's like imagine somebody who like, you know how
it's like a samurai that spends like three years or 10 years
practicing one attack. This is what it was like for
her. It was insane the amount of depth that she had of knowledge
of this. This was it was nuts. This is basically the equivalent
of being like my mom knew everything about Star Trek, right?
Like when you when you just know everything about like something
that's not really relevant, it's not like helpful. It's not constructive.
Like it can be fine, but it's like dude, why did your mom devote
that much time to to that that thing that is like not helpful?
She could be helping Cash Patel right now.
What do you mean by making stuff up and we're not going to do
Sure. Sure. Sure. We We just needed a lot more Qon people under
Cash Patel and the FBI and things would have just been solved.
Okay. They had all the knowledge. They could have they could
have helped him find and you have to methodical and we have to
talk about this. We're reviewing not just the video. We're reviewing
ev, you know, everything
as meticulously as we can because that's what we owe the American
people. That's our job. Yeah. And I don't want to rush to the
sticks or the podium and just say, "Hey, look what we found."
Right. And then be like, "Oh, sorry. I I forgot the 4 seconds."
You know, if we miss 4 seconds, you're be like, "Oh, well, it's
in the 4 seconds you missed." Right? So I I'm I'm How much can
you talk about what you've seen? Not yet. Um just just what I've
told you. Can you say you've seen anything?
No. That's the point that there's nothing in there like in the
video you guys. Uh that is a fun fact. Evil Johnny Bravo. Fun
fact. According to federal agents who do raids on, the biggest
common denominator is that they have Star Trek memorabilia in
their house.
Investigate Tim Pool now. Yes. Investigate Tim Pool now. Investigate
Tim Pool now. Okay, investigate him. That beanie plus the Star
Trek fandom. It's It's over. All right. Be bored. You're talking
about the video of the murder or this this But what about the
video of From the Island? Oh, that's the Sorry. So, you're talking
about two different Sorry. So, yeah. So,
again, we're going to give you I'll be right back. Again, we're
going to give you
everything we can and people have to remember. Yeah. We're not
going to revictimize women. We're not going to put that back
out there. It's not happening because then he wins. Not doing
it. You want to hate me for it? Fine. Again, logical. I think
that it's more important to put the information out without putting
out the names or anything else. You have to at least get the
people that did it. Like I'm not saying you have to put out the
names or images of them or anything, but you're telling me that
you can't even put out a list of people. You can't even say anything.
We want the clients. Yeah. There's nothing going on at all. So
the thing about releasing a list is it's like, is it
okay? Is it okay to release that list when realistically those
people's lives are going to be turned into like hell automatically,
right? and you can't prove any any crime they've done and you
know releasing that list is going to put them all in like imminent
danger essentially right all the people who are on the Epstein
list all need security for like the next 10 years am I wrong
is it okay for the FBI to release it given that I don't know
sorry go ahead
no I agree I'm saying yeah it's like it's it's like I understand
why people want it that makes total sense to me but it is a little
concerning that like oh I don't know I don't know if we can do
that I don't know if that's good all about this and it's all
to protect these girls. No, that's not it. Because here's the
problem is that and and this is why this emotional appeal doesn't
work with me at least. If they did it with Epstein, they're still
doing it right now. Do you think somebody who's like this creep
creepy insane awful person just after Epstein got arrested they
said, "Well, I guessed off the menu."
No, bro. They went to a different restaurant. Let's get some
names. Play out. I mean, I think I don't know. I actually don't
know. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
That sounds like a good argument, but I think the idea with these
people was not that they were all
overtly, right? And it's the conflation of with um like 17. It's
that if you could get video of them a 16-year-old, right? Then
that is effective blackmail material. So I don't know that it
was necessarily that they were all it was hey we want to get
these people in compromising situations so that we have leverage
over them right. So I don't know that like I mean not that I
would be against any of these people being arrested but
yeah different restaurant is crazy. It's off the menu. There
was a video of some guy or gal committing felonies on an island
and I'm in charge. Yeah. Don't you think you'd see it
if you have access to it? If I have it. Uh, why would we? Why?
Where? Where's this?
Yeah, Comey would say the same thing. What did Comey do that
was wrong that like makes you more trustworthy than him or whoever?
All of the heads of the FBI would have said the same thing. Uh,
maybe, maybe not. You guys, huh? Have you ever seen a more trustworthy
Oh, where's my cash patel? Oh, I lost it. You ever seen a more
Oh, he looks like that now.
Where? Just give me the eye picture. Okay. Have you ever seen
a more trustworthy face? Guys, have you ever seen a more trustworthy
face? Guys, if there was something wrong going on, I would tell
you. I You know, I would tell you. I would. Come on, man. Patella
is a homie. Unlike Comey. Wow. It rhymes.
Maybe not. I don't know. Like I I I don't Maybe. Period. If I
haven't If I
So, nobody got Would it be right if you have it, right? But you
can't say that you have it. There's probably like a lot of other
places it could be. I mean, Russia, China, MSAD could all have
this information. It could be held by a private third party that
we're not aware of. What? Why does he say Msad doesn't get you
away from accusing Israel of doing this, bro? That's not a cheat
code. Stop acting like it's a cheat code. Msad is Israel.
He's like trying so hard to not do anything anti-Israeli because
of his against Hassan right now. Bro, you're not fooling anybody.
It could be held by a This is why, you know, I'm sorry, but that's
like how you can detect the Grifter is he he won't lean into
the actual conspiracy that that's there. And there is smoke on
the MSAD like Epstein connection theory. There is something there,
right? I'm going to be real stuff about money to Israel all the
time. That's not the same. This is Israeli. This is Israel conspiracy
theories.
He is kind of getting away with it cuz I did not know that MSAD
equals Israel. Oh well then he's kind of getting away with it.
You know what? Maybe he's getting away with it. Yeah, I would
say Meow Meow Killer. I don't know if um saying like money to
Israel is the same thing in terms of politics.
As always been pro- Israel. I like Israel. I'm just saying that
like you can like Israel and believe that they do some too. You
don't have to like Israel doesn't have to be perfect. Okay. They
don't have to be perfect for them to be somebody you like or
a country you like. They don't have to be large conglomerate
like Black Rockck too. Uh it could be held by other politicians
that you know are just kind of tangentally involved. Uh KGB like
that. Yeah. I mean there's tons of tons of ways that this could
happen. No, we're giving you everything we have so far. Everything
we have so far is Have you guys gone over all uh Can you turn
up Cherry a smidge? No, I can't. Ch, you got to lean into your
mic a little bit though.
Is this better? That's way way loud, but thank you. A little
less is okay.
Okay.
The video that's available. Yeah, that's what I'm telling you.
That's what takes so much damn time, right? And and is there
video from the island?
Not of what you want. The the people out there have filled the
void with can't wait to see X, Y, or Z, right? Speculation. And
I'm like,
so there is footage and there are people that were at the
island. Where are they? Who was at the island? Also, can't you
cross reference this with somebody like Gillis and Maxwell? Like
you might not have in irrefutable proof, but in my opinion, maybe
this is irresponsible or selfish, but I think we Yeah, Alpha
Kai 10, I agree with you that like I It's really rough. It's
It's really rough. Kenny's getting wrecked right now. It's really
when he's giving such bad answers that feed conspiracy theories,
right? Feed conspiracy theorists. It's bizarre. English people
can't pronounce galain. I just found out that Americans today
I just found out for the first time that Americans pronounce
the word foyer as foyer. It's it is foyer. This tried to correct
me. They say correct me. He's like did you say foyer? It Yeah,
cuz that's how it's pronounced. And then he looked it up on Google
and when he saw the pronunciation spelled out, he felt like a
No, Americans the American English is foyer but they are it's
because they are this is like actually I totally understand how
they voted for Trump now they say foyer they don't say foyer
they don't admit that it's French they don't use it as it should
be used the fact that it is French is why we had to switch that
up you might be out to French people right they might be taking
over your not user Billy Joe Bush with that with that U that's
there in Voyer. Okay, I want you to understand why you are for
trying to make that comparison. Okay, there is no U in foyer.
Stop. Just stop. You're embarrassing yourself. Cherry confirmed.
Oh my god. I will vote.
That's taken out. He's taking out Elon. I'm just call me Ma right
now. I don't care. My hate for Elon predates Trump even running
for office. Trump Trump did win. Okay, that's like I that's Yeah,
we I had that argument two nights ago, I think, with people.
That's just like, dude, Trump's awesome right now. Okay, I'm
sorry. He's funny and he will win. Elon has no chance. Elon is
at his core a bullied loser. That is who he is. That was always
what he'll revert to, right? And Trump is at his core, for all
you hate him, a bully. Okay? It's why he stepped up on that stage
and bullied people into winning in 2016. The bully is always
going to win. Trump is always gonna Elon's girl. Okay. Every
single time
Elon literally tweeted out to remind people that he's rich. Like,
you lost. Why are you telling people Trump's in office for three
and a half more years? I'm I'm rich. You know,
don't take Trump's side. I'm I'll be mad at you for a long time.
I'll be mad at you forever. Yeah. Super cool, buddy. Go back
to Africa.
I deserve to know who was at the island. I think I think we deserve
to see that. That that that's that's where I'm at. It's all going
to go. Yeah. Even if they're not doing anything wrong.
Even if I didn't convict them. Come on, dude. Actually, dude,
Musk getting deported and like all of his companies getting nationalized
would be
I think they'd only really want SpaceX.
I just think that because of how he looks, you actually can say
go back to Africa.
You can. Yeah, if he was a black guy, it would not be cool. Yeah,
it would not be cool. It would not. No matter what was happening.
Yeah. And I understand that being on the island is not a guarantee
that you did weird stuff, but I like I mean I still think people
should have an idea. Yeah, it is. When you come to a four-way
stop, who has the right away? Oh, no, no, no. Not this one. Hold
on, hold on, hold on. No, no, no. What? Wrong short. Wrong short.
If you want to
America great.
You guys can help me with my thing. We got to shred a bunch of
documents. What? Whoa. What? What are you talking about, man?
Well, the thing of it is may or may not have been the official
beverage supplier of Jeffrey Epstein.
What? Jeffrey Epste? Yeah. But before you judge me, know this.
Yes, I was on the island, but only for the snorkeling. I didn't
know anything about the kids stuff. Look, 95% of what went on
down there was not. Oh, yeah. No, the other 5% that sullied the
whole operation. Yeah, you sure did, Frank. Well, you know, it
ain't just me. You guys' names are on those documents, too. Remember
what? What? Still. God damn it. Son of a No, I don't have time
for this. Well, come on and be quick. It's only a couple bucks.
Anyway, sorry. That's what Asmin just said. It's not a guarantee
you did. And it's like 95% of what went on there was just awesome
times. Okay. the other 5% with the kids, that was up. Okay, that
was really weird. I I don't I don't know about that. I really
just don't I I just I don't know about that. So, this is the
reason why I'm hesitant to be
Okay? It's a personal reason and you guys can take it or leave
it, right? This is just the way that I feel about it. This is
why I'm not definitive. I'm high probability, but I'm not definitive.
is that I've had friends, we all know this, I have had friends
that were accused of doing weird stuff.
Techone. Rich Campbell. Uh, Teone Rich
I had no
Oh, Miskf. Misk. Oh, but he's I don't know if he consider idea
about this happening. These were people that were very very close
friends of mine that I was involved with on a very very regular
basis all the time. And I had no idea that any of this happened
at all. No clue. So a proximity to a person does not guarantee
that you are aware of every bad thing that Dude, that's not the
same. What? He's saying the people who went to the island is
not a guarantee they did something wrong. What proximity do you
have to Msk? You don't talk to these people. You never go over
to their house. What do you mean? I Yes. I Nobody expects you
to have any idea what Misk is doing. Nobody expects you to have
any idea what Rich is doing or Tone. any of these people. You
You at most saw Techone for your podcast like once a week. That's
crazy. Rich is innocent. I believe Rich is innocent. I I believe
Msk did something wrong, but maybe he was too about it, so he
got blown up. And Teone's not innocent. Teone has actual proximity
to a known criminal. True. That people have done. But at the
same time, it's very suspicious. And I think it's fair that people
are suspicious. You you know, the world would say yes. Guilty
by association. Crunch. Crunch. Yes. But that's not I mean what
people what how people draw conclusions is not always accurate.
Like I mean just because people draw a conclusion something looking
bad doesn't mean that somebody did bad. Yeah. Exactly right.
They'd be hung in court of public opinion. You understand that
you've been to the island. Maybe you didn't do anything wrong
but listen to your chatters. They're out for blood. I mean you
you're really telling me that like you can't get any information
from anybody else and all these people that went to the island.
There was nothing about this at all. Oh. Um, I don't know why.
I just thought of this right now, but apparently Lav and her
husband are going to stay with Darius. I'm sorry. What? Apparently
Lav and her husband are going to stay with Darius. I've heard
this.
Like, I think they're like going to I think they're going to
I don't know if it's to collab or I actually don't know. I literally
don't know. Does Lab know how gross that house is?
I don't know. No, there's a new husband. This is Goonar. This
is Goonar. Yeah, Goon has to stay there for a month. This is
like for So, so Darius is going to do like, "Hey, let's go downtown
and collab." And for Laugh and Gooner, it's going to be like
Fear Factor. There's like totally different content going on
each stream. One of them's One of them's doing Fear Factor. The
other one's just, you know, having a great time. I think L the
animals. You probably would like that goat.
Yeah, GMO. Think that they should release this information anyway.
Kind of funny. Not going to lie. I would have thought that was
off limits for Darius because of Destiny. Uh, and the funny thing
is is Lav, you don't control Lav. She is definitely going to
make comments on that stream. Yeah, I that is interesting, isn't
it? Oh, the other thing I thought about was um I think what I
should have asked people to find a pattern of if they were like
le if people had DMs with this guy. I just love to find uh people's
like opinions what they were right of sorry not people's when
when Destiny like talks to girls was he what was his opinion
of Darius cuz I think back to like that Mackie clip that Darius
had if you guys remember when when Darius talked about Mackie
95 and he talked about how Destiny basically messaged her and
was like Darius is like really creepy and weird you shouldn't
you probably shouldn't be around him at all. I I kind of wonder
if that happens more often and I wonder if Darius is kind of
sick of it and maybe that's where um the Lav collab is coming
from. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. Why I do and if people
are mad about it or whatever. Too bad. Too [__] bad.
The best interest of the public is more important than your reputation.
That's what I think.
Uh, Schumafine, the only reason y'all believe this is because
Teone is so bad at responding and just digs himself a hole and
he's the most unlikable human on Earth. Uh, he's literally just
lied about the allegations against him multiple times. Scuba
Fiend, if you just if you're innocent, I don't believe you like
lie as like frivolously and as often as Techno does. Like, like
literally, he has given you way more reason to not trust him
than the woman's given you reason to not trust her. I and your
inability to understand that is just crazy to me, right? She
hasn't neither of those women have just been like lying
Teone has te's lying. And Skuma is like, "Yeah, he's bad at responding."
That's that's a very interesting way to put lying. That's maliciously
lying. Yes. Maliciously making things up and lying about people.
He's just not good at public speaking.
It's true. Too bad. And and if people hate you and they they
think that you should go to jail, too bad. There's going to be
collateral damage and that's life. People don't realize someone
going to the island once doesn't even mean they knew what was
going on uh when they went. It could be more complicated for
certain visitors cases than others. You're right. Here's the
other thing I've been asking for right openly. If you have information
on this, call us. Tell us. The best resource we have is the American
people in the world, right? Get me the tail numbers. get me the
flight, you know, get me new information and I will run that
down. So, this narrative might not be accurate that there's video
of these guys doing this. Exactly. Is it possible that the video
was taken and destroyed? Yeah. Well, you're talking about what,
decades worth of stuff, right? Remember, we have what we have
pursuant to lawful
uh search warrants and authorities from the case that was done
uh however many years ago was done. That's what we have. If other
people have other stuff and they want to give it to us,
bring it. Have you guys reviewed everything that you have? That's
a crazy comment. That's I mean we have and now we're figuring
out how to
right put it out. Since we were talking about fake news, this
is going to come up because it's been going on since we've been
recording here. Uh oh. Uh Elon and Trump seem to be in a bit
of a spat. Joe, you want to check the tweet that Elon just put
out a little bit ago?
Oh [__]
Oh my god. I will. Oh [__] I'm sorry. Time to drop
the really big bomb. Donald Trump is in the Epstein files. That's
okay. Hold
Wait. There's no way this is like That's okay. I don't mean to
be an actual conspiracy theorist, but the fact that they'd have
this whole segment on Epstein and then Elon would tweet immediately
about Epstein, there's no way. Is there what what is the time
of the studio at the time of that tweet?
Well, it could it be that Elon is watching Joe Rogan? But does
Joe stream it live? I don't know if Joe streams it live. Oh,
no. No, he doesn't. Yeah, I don't think Joe Yeah, he doesn't
stream it live.
I I don't know, dude. I don't know. I He's listening. He's listening.
The real reason they have not been made public. Have a nice day.
Jesus Christ. I'm not participating in any of that
Absolute cinema. Yeah. Have a nice That don't trust that. I'm
sorry. I hate to be that guy right now. I don't trust that. What
the day? DJD sometimes gets phone away. They're going back and
forth about different things and yeah, listen. Well, he said
he was disappointed in Elon.
Told him to leave. Jesus Christ, that's a crazy thing to say.
How does he know? Does he know that Donald Trump is in the Epstein
Files? Does he have access to the Epste Files? I don't know how
he would, but I'm just staying out of the Trump thing that's
way outside.
This guy This guy's like seen somebody go like get like a what
is it? Colombian necktie. Is that what it is? He I feel like
he's seen somebody get like who was like in government like they
pulled somebody into a back room and just like viciously murdered
them and he's just sitting here like I'm not doing anything.
I'm not involved. I'm shut the [__] up. Don't I might
be the director of the FBI. I don't know what's going on. But
it it would help if you guys called us and told us if you know
anything. I wouldn't know anything. I don't know. Guys, could
you help me with my job as director of the FBI? I'm trying to
crowdsource this Epstein investigation. Okay, guys. Does anyone
know? Right after he says that, Elon posts on Twitter, "All right,
I'll help you guys out."
Dude, he he doesn't want one of those exploding head implants
like they gave JFK. Dude, it's it's wild how little this guy
wants to participate. Okay,
they know my lane and that ain't it. I just don't I mean, I understand
he owns Twitter. I think it's bad for your mental health. I think
posting things public all day and arguing with people all day
is bad for you. Well, what a revolutionary what a revolutionary
take from Joe Rogan. Guys, I think Twitter might not be great
for your mental health. Okay, you rais a great point. Sorry to
cut you off. Go ahead. Ew. No. Half of Hold on. Oh, that was
so gross. If you if you donate cherry ASMR, I'll do Asthma ASMR
right now. You raise a great point. Sorry to cut you off. No,
that is so gross.
You raise a You know, there's just like so much crust in there
or something. Why is it so scratchy?
You raised a great point. Sorry. I don't like it. Yeah. No, it's
not great. Half of what we have to respond to are is the click
army on social media.
Dude, I I I I don't know. There's a bit more of this. By the
way, I was taking a I I saw there's a little bit more uh more
going on with this. Okay. No spying FB. Does he pull up the Does
he pull up the doxing director? The thing is also, why isn't
Cash Patel going after the people that are making these death
threats on the internet? I mean, you fired all these FBI agents.
Shouldn't you have just had had some of them go after that? Uh,
you get to part where Cash got swatted, dude. My Twitter algo
is [__] right now. And my like scrolling Twitter
is like not helpful for me. I need to ref I need to fix my Twitter
algo again. I like I think I watch too many like funny animal
videos and now it just gives me all of the most popular posts
and I'm like, I don't care. I don't care. Stop showing me this.
Stop showing me. Stop showing me this. It's uh I need to fix
it. It used to be good. Now it's Now it's bad for your mental
health. Yeah, but Asminold has a good system, okay, of just going
through and like liking the things he wants to cover on stream
and then he just pulls up his Twitter his Twitter likes and they're
making these death threats on the internet.
I mean, you fired all these FBI agents. Shouldn't you have just
had some of them go after that? Uh you get to part where Cash
got swatted. Well, I don't know. It sounds so sketch. There is
the video there. There's the video right there. 23 video. Okay,
hold on. He's going to watch it. Give me two seconds. I'll be
right back. Those minutes game wars. Yeah, I know. We're going
to get to this in just a minute. Okay. Donald Trump is in the
Epstein files. That's the real reason they have not been made
public. Have a nice day. Jesus Christ. I'm not participating
in any of that
Have a nice day. DJ. Someone did take his phone away. They're
going back and forth about different things. And man, listen.
Well, he said he was disappointed in Elon. Yeah, man. Jesus Christ.
That's a crazy thing to say. That is how does he know? It's a
really crazy thing to say that Donald Trump is in the Epstein
Files. Does he have access to the Epstein files? I don't know
how he would, but I'm just staying out of the
Trump are they doing uh I know my lane and that ain't it. I just
don't I mean, I understand he owns Twitter. I think it's bad
for your mental health. Ultra methylene blue.
Oh, I'm back. Does Asmin not realize that he just watched the
thing clip he watched before? Or I'm like, wait, he was going
to talk about the swatting thing and then he just didn't pull
up the swatting thing. He pulled up the Trump Elon thing. Does
he even aware that he did that or
cash swatting? Hold on. Cash swatting. Cash. Yes, this is the
one from Charlie Kirk. This is what I actually wanted to watch.
Cash Patel is so worthless outside of like um outside of uh populism
that he is trying to use like populist rhetoric while being the
director of the FBI. It's beyond.
And as director of the FBI of responsibility, I'm not just going
to bring a case because somebody hurt me. They did and they continue
to do it. My house just got swatted yesterday. What? Yeah. But
you got swatted? Oh yeah. The head of
FBI gets swatted. Yeah.
Head of the FBI. These people play it's it's the
head of the FBI gets swatted. What?
Yeah. These people play it's it's the ultimate height of hypocrisy.
They have two sets of rules. One against you and one for them.
And
who's them? You are them. You are official. You are the highest
law enforcement agent in the land. You are them. That's you.
No, he's just one of us. Yeah. One for us and one for them. Who?
What? Shouldn't you be fixing that? Shouldn't you be able to
fix that cash? That's like literally what your job is. I mean,
technically there's like a difference and it's like local law
enforcement versus, you know, he's federal law enforcement. Technically,
that's true, but at the same time, like who's them? And why is
it a system for them? Why is it a system? Like that fundamentally
cuts against the idea that it would be some like coordinated
network of people, right? That it's like local governments or
something. Local governments, local police departments. He is
he is the swamp. He is leading the police of the swamp. The rhetoric
still works on those low IQ MA on the low IQ MAGA majority. It
probably does. You're right. You're not wrong.
Unfortunately, you're not wrong.
Okay. Now, next thing. We've got two options. One is I What did
I do with this video? Did I Did I close this? I must have. Drew
Pavloo YouTube.
Uh, what? I don't know. I just wanted to say no.
Okay, fair enough. Drew Pavloo debated Alex Jones on Ukraine.
Pavlu on Drew P.
Pavloo debating Alex Jones on Ukraine from two days ago. Okay.
Oh, Merc
Okay, we might have to do Merc Darius. Oh, but I wanted to do
this real quick before before real quick. Real real fast. Real
fast. Okay. Embarrassing and horrible journalism taking a quote
from a satire Instagram page and presenting it as facts. Like,
what are we doing here, guys? This is Stephen A. Smith and PBD.
Let's go. Can you type in Britney Grinder? I bring you on. I
bring I'd have fun with you, Britney. Britney Grinder. Uh uh.
Well, she says, Yeah, she says right there. Watch this. Every
time we play her, there's this commotion, like this loud rumbling
from the stands. Turns out it's people, thousands of them, just
sitting there watching on purpose. It's very disruptive. That's
clearly satire. Yeah, that's clearly not real. What? That's the
joke. The joke is nobody watches the WNBA and Britney Griner
is so used to people not watching the WNBA that they that she's
like, "What the are they doing? What? They're just sitting there
watching like on purpose. It's up. How could you How in the world
could you possibly be fueled by this the little it it's literally
called the sports meme is the page that's it's called the sports
she says WNBA games used to be a chill quiet place you could
bring your lamp I pray I pray to God that Stephen A Smith is
about to go you realize you're right stop and relax maybe even
get a little work done but now it's like there's large gatherings
of people watching us from understand the stand. Some of them
are yelling crazy [__] about what they're seeing,
putting unfair pressure on us to score like we're there for their
entertainment. You are. The whole thing is
this, by the way, this guy is one of the most watched podcasts
on the internet. Toxic. I saw a guy with his daughter in the
crowd. Both of them yelling. Couldn't hear what they were saying
exactly, but it was either my performance or some light racism.
Light racism. But here's where I'm going with this. So, the WNBA
says they want to get paid more. They're saying this year they're
going to make a dude. I I Somebody has to be laughing going you
this is a bit. Somebody thinks this is a bit. That has to be
the laughing, right? There's no way if it's like incredulous
laughing and they're like laughing at Britney Grryer based on
that quote. Everybody here needs to go uh somewhere to a better
place. Wherever the better place is. Gab billion dollars. That's
what they're saying. Okay. For the first time ever now that Caitlyn
Clark is hurt for two weeks, did you see ticket prices? Insane.
Let me read you the ticket ticket ticket prices after Caitlyn
Clark's been hurt for two weeks. All right, so let's go through
this. Caitlyn Clark absence is having an immediate impact beyond
the court. According to data shared by Yahoo Sports via Tickpic,
prices for two specific Indiana Fever away games against the
Chicago Sky and a Washington I believe the Indiana Fever is Caitlyn
Clark dropped sharply after Clark was sidelined. Before the injury,
the lowest ticket available for Fever's matchup in Chicago was
$86. For the game in Washington, fans needed at least $41 to
get in. After the news of Clark's absence, those get in price
fell. Those get in prices fell to $25 from 86 and $14 from
41. What the hell is going on with WNBA that they cannot handle
all this attention that they're getting as well as the hate and
anger towards Caitlyn
First things first,
no. Stephen A. Smith, you've been talking about running for president.
Don't end your presidential run on the podcast. Yes. Yes, he's
talked about it. It's stupid, but like he's actually gonna end
any possible ability to take him seriously if he answers this
seriously. Respectfully,
I want Shannon Sharp to
Britney Grryer was in a Russian prison. You would think that
somebody who is now free back in America on a home on home
No. No. Would not have too much to complain about.
No.
Stephen A. Smith, stop. Stephen A. Smith, stop saying things.
Sorry. Go.
No. Like, I thought he caught the first IG post. He knew that
was a meme page,
I I thought maybe he did. He didn't. I thought he was like laughing
and going like, "Oh, but no." Yeah, he put his hand over his
face. But I guess it's because he was what? Vibing with the complaint.
Uh like actually Yeah. Actually like disappointed in Britney
Grinder for speaking. Soy facing. Yeah. That's crazy.
Especially
something like
this. Fans in every sport. She described the fans. Yeah. It doesn't
matter what sport you are. It doesn't matter which what you pick.
Dude, these guys are getting filtered so hard by the internet
right now. I'm sorry. It's I can't make that. Ah, you have to
be smarter than this. That's how fans act in every arena. In
every arena. So, and then when you clearly she's not remembering
who they let out to get her back. The merchant of death.
What is that relevant to with this an arms? Why would that be
relevant to this meme dealer
that wanted to kill American citizens? According to the reports,
that's who they let out. Mhm. for her. You would think that you
would be honestly like basically I think if you started
if you started like sterilization lists for America, every single
like subscriber who watches more than an hour a week of PBD's
podcast, that would be where I'd start. That would just be right
there. Literally, any of those people shouldn't have kids. They
should never have kids. You are you've literally been filtered
by society. I'm sorry. You watch this guy. You think this guy's
compelling in any way, you should be out. You should be out.
You should be done smiling. You would be ecstatic. You would
be happy. And something like this wouldn't phase you at all.
The fact that it does is disturbing. I'll leave it at that. Dude.
Yeah. Vinnie's Vinnie's bad. Vinnie Oana the the ex smackthead
who reddest man on podcasts today. America's tomato. America's
favorite tomato. All right.
Get him out. 30 minutes an hour is too len 30 minutes an hour
is too lenient. No, no, no, no, no, no. I said I said if you
watch more than an hour a week of this. Like you could watch
it to meme on it. Sure. But if you if you watch it seriously
for like an hour a week or more, get the out. Just get out. Just
get out. Just get out. Get out. You've been filtered. The filter
The filter hit you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
sorry. Good lord.
Boring. Okay. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, guys. I'm sorry. Uh guys,
we need four subs to get another hour on the stream. Okay. We
needed four subs right now to get another hour on the stream.
We're going to get there. I know we're going to get there. Or
20 bucks. Either one. And we're going to do the I think we're
going to do some of the Merk stuff. Ry link me some. I don't
even know. Apparently, we're going to get to the part where Good
Lord. Okay. Apparently, we're gonna get to the part where Murk
tries to steal the goat. They drive away. They get all angry.
I think it's like mostly uh we'll see. We'll see what's going
on. Okay. Darius bought a goat. People got drunk. There was a
fight that happened. Okay.
Uh revoked 7890. Thank you for the gifted sub. I don't know why
my I spent like an hour trying to debug my audio today. I thought
I had it working. Apparently, I do not have it working. So, it's
very annoying to me. I don't know if like this would make it
work better or what. I don't know how I can make it work better.
It's very annoying to me that it doesn't work. But, I think we're
going to start with the uh the merc stuff. Merk and Darius fighting
over the goat.
So, basic intro. This is what this is what Ry wrote out for me.
Darius got a goat. Darius got a goat. Okay. Oh, hold on. Sophia
gifted five. Sophia, thank you very much for the five. Super
appreciate it. Sophia, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Go. Thank
you. Thank you. Train.
An abs total hype train. M. Thank you for the gifted sub, dude.
I swear to God, I fixed his audio and it's like totally [__]
now. I gave you the old Yeah. Yeah. Sure, sure, Ry. I'm just
I'm just introing it for people. Okay, now we got we got the
subs in, guys. Okay, I'll add the hour to the stream and we're
good to go. Not that you can't sub more, but I'm just saying
that the subs are here. We're so good to go. I'm sure you'll
get the audio fixed next stream.
That's six for today. God, sorry. I'm trying to reset the subs
real quick and then we are starting with the merc thing, but
I got to reset the subs really quickly. It's making me log into
Botrix again. Love to see it. I love to log into Botrix instead
of just going to my thing. I love that it makes me do it every
day. Every day. Cookies don't work. No persistent storage on
the website is so awesome. Welldesigned. Cool. There we go. We're
reset. Goals for this. Like when I get 10 nice comments that
I've said on stream to you, there's like something that I should
get. Like money.
Like money. Okay, we could probably do it. Yes, we've got squeezes
POV over dummy. We do. We've got Squeezes POV. Lots of squeeze
time stamps here. Okay. Okay.